this video is brought to you by babel
[Music]
what's up guys michael here to talk
about the thing that makes america truly
exceptional no not butter statues of
jesus although that is magnificent and
garrett earned his win today we're
talking gun violence in america i know
it's heavy americans are 25.2 times more
likely to be murdered by guns than
people in the top 22 wealthiest nations
on earth and in 2020 death by firearm
surged 30 percent among american kids
and adolescents dethroning motor vehicle
crashes as their most common cause of
death and if you're less of a human life
and more of a numbers person
gun violence costs america an average of
280 billion dollars a year in medical
bills and lost productivity also it's
really dark that it's someone's job to
figure out how much productivity is lost
to gun violence and yet an alien coolly
observing american pop culture or
american politics could reasonably
conclude that guns rule that's because
despite the carnage they inflict a
sizable portion of america continues to
really really love them they occupy a
special protected place in our cultural
psyche which makes just about any
conversation about policy surrounding it
super polite and totally civilized no
not at all it's like little kids arguing
about about toys except their guns
that can kill people but let's put our
big boy pants on and take a deep dive
into america's gun violence problem
where it comes from and what it says
about us as a nation welcome to this
wisecrack deep dive was america's gun
violence inevitable
but before we get into it i want to talk
about this video sponsor babel it's
summer and to me
summer means vacation and part of the
fun of visiting new places is learning a
new language to help you fit in like a
local or at least as a well-intentioned
visitor who's trying their best and
babel is a language learning app that
can help you build your language skills
faster than you can say bon voyage one
of the things that's so great about
babel is its focus on practical
conversations you'd have in the real
world like
asking for directions ordering in
restaurants and arguing about who's the
more powerful bald man bruce willis or
vin diesel and the lessons are designed
by actual humans not algorithms which
adds another layer of actual usefulness
to each 10-minute lesson with its
multiple formats like podcasts and games
in addition to straight up lessons babel
sets you up for success from the start
as soon as wisecrack's finance
department authorizes my very important
research trip to france that is not a
vacation i know i'll be able to rely on
babel to help me brush up on my french
visit the link in the description to get
65
off your subscription babel has proven
to have you speaking your new language
in just three weeks and it's backed up
by a 20-day money-back guarantee so hit
that link in the description to get 65
off babble and now
back to the show guns are more than a
bit player in american history by some
historians accounts the american
revolution broke out over anger at
britain for stopping shipments of
firearms to america and for confiscating
colonists limited weapons stockpiles i
still think the story about tea is cute
though the founding fathers saw guns as
a useful tool for hunting and for
collective protection owning a gun was
mostly mandatory for a certain
subsection of white men and some
colonies required them to carry their
guns to church and public meetings
imagine getting tooled up and going to
mass oh you wouldn't go to mass because
they hated catholics then as tension
between the colonies in britain heated
up gun seemed like the only line of
defense against an oppressive monarch
gun culture looked very different though
guns were privately owned but they were
seen as collective assets a shared
stockpile to be used by citizen militias
and colonial legislation dictated that
in case of emergency the government
could briefly repossess your gun for use
in battle yes they could literally come
into your house and take your gun
another important thing the founding
fathers didn't only love guns they also
loved gun control like how as a white
man you could only own a gun if you met
certain criteria like having a clean
criminal record swearing loyalty to the
union or in some places not being
catholic which if you were to witness
one of my family reunions would make a
lot of sense
too much booze for guns and of course
black people essentially couldn't own
guns at all and even if you did meet all
the criteria to own a gun your use of it
was heavily regulated you had to
register it with the government and
there were regular inspections to make
sure it was ready to be used by the
militia certain places had even stricter
laws in boston you couldn't keep a
loaded firearm inside a building not
even your own home basically the
founding fathers seemed to have believed
in gun control measures that were
conducive to public safety and wigs they
also really believed in wigs i guess
they were self-hating bald men and thus
i don't respect them all of this
amounted to an early america that wasn't
an especially violent place to be except
for the whole war with britain and
genocide against native american stuff
not a lot of guns were made here and
those that were were handcrafted by
gunsmiths who like today's taskrabbits
typically had to work multiple other
gigs because there wasn't enough demand
for their product shout out to all my
real housewives and lower tier bachelor
contestants out there but in the early
19th century the fledgling us army
wanted to beef up specifically by
acquiring uniform guns with
interchangeable parts previously every
gun had been custom-made with custom
measurements so industrialists started
inventing the technology that would make
gunsmiths irrelevant infrastructure for
the mass production of standardized guns
their plan was to score big government
contracts and make bank selling guns
commercially to individuals didn't even
occur to them one key player in this was
samuel colt also known as dr samuel colt
a performer known for staging big shows
where he gave people too much laughing
gas
but this guy saw more potential in the
mass manufacturing of guns and he went
all in inventing the revolving cylinder
which allowed guns to hold multiple
rounds of ammunition rendering them
significantly more lethal definitely not
as fun as laughing gas
gun makers would continue to come up
with other ways to make their guns more
lethal as a selling point but colt
quickly realized he had two
really big problems one the army didn't
want to buy large quantities of these
newfangled guns and two operating at
capacity his factory could create far
more guns than he could sell there just
wasn't enough demand for something that
at the time was largely seen as an
instrument of war so colt and his fellow
gun manufacturers had to get creative
they had to artificially manufacture a
civilian demand for their product
what what a thing to artificially
invent demand for a product
that's crazy that's i'm glad that no i'm
glad they stopped doing it i'm glad
that's never happened since that would
suck to live in that world one company
hilariously patented a cane gun which
yes is a cane that shoots bullets
tragically it wasn't a big hit
[Music]
for his part colt was all about
marketing and heavy discounts but
frustrated by lackluster american demand
he started thinking internationally a
war happy europe was all too willing to
fill the void as historian pamela the
hog puts it it was the european regimes
of the mid-1800s and battled with each
other and brimming with imperial
ambition where the demand for guns ran
highest colt began to see the world as
his market arming europe would embolden
those countries to encroach on asia and
then yay asia would need guns too which
is
very cool and not at all cynical logic
mr colt dr colt he traveled abroad
bringing lavish gifts to important
statesmen and arming anyone who could
sign a check that included supplying
weapons to russia and turkey in their
ongoing war it's fun when when people
killing each other is good for business
by the 1800s nearly all guns in europe
were made in america via what was
functionally the beginning of modern
globalization but back to the 1850s for
a sec gun makers still faced a problem
gun sales were better during times of
war but relying on government contracts
meant poor sales during times of peace
one of colt's competitors oliver
winchester had an idea what if instead
of wedding himself to american
government contracts he cultivated a
commercial gun market winchester
imagined his ideal customers not to be
soldiers but to be what hogg calls
citizen defenders who would buy guns in
defense of their homes and land this is
when gun ownership started being less
about the early logic of collective
defense against an oppressive government
and more about individual self-defense
against a dangerous frontier the
struggle to cultivate this dream market
was for a time abated by the civil war
which as you might imagine created a
huge demand for guns and for a man like
colt it offered two hungry markets the
union and the confederacy that's right
this ambitious dick bag armed both sides
of the conflict causing the new york
times to accuse him of treason but the
war's end brought new problems hundreds
of thousands of firearms flooded the
markets so many former soldiers now
owned guns that the gun market turned
abysmal and gun makers looked back to
international customers and they were
not discerning as scholars rachel stahl
and suzekralot write manufacturers took
advantage of laissez-faire economics and
sold weapons to interested customers no
matter who or where they might have been
arming despots and dictators alike and
presumably finally
the catholics american guns spread
everywhere from fiji where they replaced
boomerangs to alaska where they armed
inuit people for hunting at the time in
say britain gun dealers scrutinized each
customer's character and integrity in
america the vibe was more you get a gun
he gets a gun she gets a gun the dog
gets a gun take this gun for 50 off guns
so we know by now that civilians owning
guns is not as american as butter jesus
so how did america go from gun agnostic
to gun loving advertising and lots of it
marketing historian robert henning
argues that advertisements were key to
inventing and shaping american gun
culture this advertising relied on the
romanticization of the wild west where
the well-armed from tears man was
literally manifesting manifest destiny
or just literally manifesting destiny i
don't know as legal professor adam
winkler notes in his book gunfight
cultural observers have argued that the
frontier was not only the root of the
american character but also the origin
of america's propensity for violence the
wild westification of america was
envisioned through promotional imagery
of western from tears men and taglines
like god created men colonel colt made
them equal okay so now he's he's mr colt
dr colt
and colonel colts i don't buy it
meanwhile wildly popular dime store
novels written on the civilized east
coast told violent tales of great
gunslingers in the west cementing the
frontier's legacy in this way guns were
presented in popular media as the
antithesis of proper east coast
industrial society despite the fact that
guns were solely being manufactured in
places like new haven connecticut and so
the east mythologizing the west began to
really arm the country winchester also
recognized the importance of imbuing
guns with a sort of symbolic importance
anthropomorphizing their supposed
character the great advantage of this
rifle over all others consists in the
moral effect it has he wrote i've never
read a book of moral philosophy or
someone's like
chapter 2
why guns are virtuous guns were starting
to become a sign of self-sovereignty a
symbol of american individualism so you
might be thinking america's idea of
violence came out of the west so the
west must have been super violent right
not so fast cowboy the wild west had
tons of guns but it also had something
in common with the founding fathers lots
of gun control you may picture the wild
west as one big rowdy gunslinging saloon
but evidence shows that murder rates
were minimal most people felt so safe
they didn't even lock their doors as
winkler notes almost everyone carried
firearms in the untamed wilderness which
was full of dangerous natives outlaws
and bears in the frontier towns however
where people lived and businesses
operated the law often forbade people
from toting their guns around some of
this was strategic frontier towns were
small but wanted to grow and to do that
they needed to seem safe while lore of
western gunfights mainstreamed guns and
cowboys as twin symbols of an
individualistic america the actual west
knew that they couldn't afford to be as
violent as their mythology still the
romanticization of the west was a highly
successful marketing strategy and around
the turn of the century gun sales were
booming this is when the gun really went
from serving as a tool of necessity to
serving a psychological need as hogg
puts it what was once needed now had to
be love which would be a really
beautiful quote if it wasn't describing
a gun luckily it was the perfect time
for that historian kristen hoganson
among others has argued that
gender-based anxieties at the time
engineered a new preoccupation with a
return to manliness via boxing football
war and of course
guns for president teddy roosevelt the
gun was a remedy against the rapid
changes of modern life which had brought
about a corporate economy antithetical
to the individualist american mythos
anyway the mystique of the gun obscured
the fact that the gun industry was as
much a part of the modern corporate
economy as any other when world war one
hit the gun industry had to step up with
winchester securing the contracts to
immediately produce the equivalent of
five years worth of orders ironically
this time war was a risky proposition
for gun makers they had to take out
massive loans to expand their factories
to accommodate all the demand and after
the war many were drowning in debt they
tried to rebuild via massive advertising
campaigns that continued into the
mid-1900s they targeted among other
groups women and boys as young as 12 via
pamphlets that raved about four american
boys who are famous rifle shots which is
a real advertising slogan and not
something written by a spambot
winchester retailers were told to put a
winchester into the hands of every youth
in your town with the overall goal of
arming millions of boys aged 10 to 16
which is objectively a pretty wild thing
to put on your vision board it's crazy
that now we're worried about young
people playing video games but back then
we just gave them guns advertisements
stoked fears that the war had come home
and danger lurked on every street colt
adds warned that responsibility for the
protection of your property your home
your loved ones is too serious and
matter to be entrusted to an arm of
doubtful lineage guns were touted as
totems of masculinity protecting men
from becoming soft images of wholesome
young red-blooded american men could
assure anyone worried that america was
not in fact degenerating into a nation
of lounge lizard anemics as the
industrial manufacturer news bureau
delightfully put it also if lounge
lizard anemics isn't a band yet someone
watching this
start that band you know you'll have
good merch advertisements some modeled
after liquor companies were teaching
people to truly love their guns
gradually the sentiment helped create
consumers who saw guns not as objects of
necessities but as objects of desire and
like me buying merch outside of a dead
show these kinds of consumers would buy
way more than they needed the lore of
american gun culture was persuasive by
1959 winchester could straight-facely
boast the slogan winchester more than a
gun an american legend a legend they had
authored themselves but
okay
sure as hogg puts it one answer to the
question why do americans love guns is
simply that we were invited to do so by
those who made and sold them at the
moment when their products had shed much
of their more practical utilitarian
value still popular media ran with
winchester's narrative offering that
casual assertions that americans had
always loved guns or that they had a
timeless tradition of gun fluency that's
hog rights for much of our history
americans are actually pretty bad at
actually shooting the guns in fact the
nra was formed after the civil war
specifically because some veterans were
alarmed at the horrible marksmanship of
union soldiers for much of its history
the nra was more about target shooting
competitions than influencing politics
though today its rhetoric is fiercely
anti-government the early nra relied on
major subsidies to help build gun ranges
and taxpayers even got the privilege of
funding their annual competition in ohio
but then came the 1920s and 30s and with
it prohibition and a huge spike in urban
crime and again with prohibition like
why is everyone always trying to keep
the catholics from doing what they love
this violence was personified by the
ruthless mobster who was typically armed
with a tommy gun a highly lethal machine
gun that caused violence on a scale once
unimaginable gun control remained a
tough political sell though by now gun
manufacturers in america's war
department had a symbiotic relationship
the war department feared that if gun
businesses couldn't find markets during
times of peace they wouldn't be prepared
for times of war it's hard to imagine
now but during this era the nra actually
stepped in and lobbied states to enact
gun control measures the sheer magnitude
of mob violence created enough political
will in congress to pass the national
firearms act the law and subsequent
additions to it effectively halted the
proliferation of machine guns
permanently retrospectively historians
view it as proof that successful gun
control is possible in america
and then things were basically chill on
the gun front until
this happened you may have heard of the
black panthers an activist group that
organized against racism and police
brutality and believed that arming black
people was the best path towards racial
justice though they're maybe best known
for carrying guns and having really good
monochromatic outfits they most
importantly provided community resources
like their free breakfast program for
children leader huey newton argued that
the civility of the civil rights
movement hadn't fixed anything and more
radical action was necessary at one
point this took the form of 30 armed
black panthers legally wielding guns as
they protested at the california state
house now's a good moment to talk about
the link between racism and gun culture
gun regulation has been used for
centuries to block black people's access
to guns in colonial times enslaved
people and even free black people
weren't allowed to own guns because
colonists feared they'd use them to rise
up hell the kkk began as a gun control
organization no seriously it formed
after the civil war to confiscate guns
from black men including veterans guns
became an important means of protection
for freed southern black people to fight
violent racism with some black men
forming militias to stop lynchings a
century later the black panthers
similarly decided that carrying guns for
self-defense was the only way they could
gain respect and safety and that really
freaked out white people in fact the
panthers so alarmed lawmakers that they
helped inspire the strictest national
gun regulation america had ever seen the
gun control act of 1968 along with the
omnibus crime control and safe streets
act these laws were also inspired in
part by collective grief over a series
of political assassinations including
mlk jfk and robert kennedy the laws
expanded federal licensing for guns and
they forbade ex-felons people with
certain mental illnesses illegal drug
users and children from owning guns and
it restricted imports of so-called
saturday night special guns which were
frequently used in crime and different
from saturday night fever guns which
were real sparkly and play disco music
when you shot them note that the nra
supported some of these measures and
even reluctantly endorsed the law and
yet
even as political will favored gun
control the gun industry still received
some special protection from higher ups
it was the sole industry to be exempt
from oversight via the new consumer
product safety commission created in
1972 according to the trace this is
because house representatives feared a
slippery slope that would lead the
agency to confiscate people's guns this
functionally means that there's more
federal oversight over a toy gun than a
real one
which is too depressing to be funny
seriously it means that the government
has more oversight over this plastic
piece of crap than a gun
that that shoots bullets i don't know oh
it also has real consequences plenty of
pointed out the gun manufacturers could
make guns safer by fixing flaws and
trigger locks or personalizing guns so
they can be used only by their owner but
without federal oversight there's no
incentive for the industry to make sure
all guns sold meet minimum safety
standards but back to 1968 the gun
control measures that did make it
through congress would have a
complicated legacy as winkler notes if
it hadn't been for the black panthers
there might never have been a modern gun
rights movement that's because he
explains these new strict laws which
were aimed largely at disarming urban
black leftist radicals led to a backlash
by rural white conservatives now you may
be wondering why we haven't mentioned
one of the essential talking points of
the gun rights debate in america the
second amendment which reads a
well-regulated militia being necessary
to the security of a free state the
right of the people to keep and bear
arms shall not be infringed there's a
good reason it hasn't come up though
until the 1960s the second amendment
wasn't one of the popular kits it didn't
play into the gun debate and was
generally ignored by legal scholars the
supreme court did use it to uphold
challenges to the 1934 law arguing that
sawed-off shotguns and machine guns
wouldn't be used by a state militia and
thus could be regulated this was the
militia interpretation of the amendment
that it only protected gun rights
insofar as they would apply to arming a
citizen militia but scholars in the 60s
and 70s started arguing for a more
individual interpretation of the second
amendment and the nra went ham on this
interpretation even bolting an excerpt
of the amendment to the outside of their
headquarters eventually the individual
interpretation would be borne out in a
supreme court decision on district of
columbia vs heller in 2008 which
overturned dc's ban on handguns in a
hotly controversial decision the
question of the individual vs militia
interpretation remains contested by
scholars for his part back in 1991
former chief justice warren berger
called the individual interpretation of
the second amendment one of the greatest
pieces of fraud
i repeat the word fraud on the american
public
by special interest groups
that i have ever seen in my lifetime
we're not going to go too deep on the
second amendment and not just because
the debate is pretty boring the thing is
we actually don't think this clause of
the constitution is as essential to the
gun debate as it's been made out to be
because let's say you do take the
strongest individualist interpretation
of the amendment holding that the
founding fathers believed in the
protected individual right to own a gun
well the founding fathers as you know
also believed in lots of gun control so
clearly they felt that this right could
be infringed on if it meant protecting
public safety that is to say you can
both believe in the individual's
interpretation of the amendment and
believe that gun control measures are
necessary because you
yes you
contain multitudes but back to the 70s
now armed with revelatory constitutional
backup the nra leapt into the decade
establishing an official lobbying wing
for both the nra and cocaine the 70s
were a hell of a decade ironically
though mostly white the group borrowed a
lot of the black panther's arguments
that guns were necessary for
self-defense not only in the home but on
the street where bumbling cops surely
couldn't be relied upon there was some
lingering tension though between the old
guards who had cooperated on gun control
laws and newer more radical members who
believed any form of gun control was a
slippery slope to having their gun room
raided by communist the anti-gun control
extremists staged a coup at the nra's
national meeting in 77 setting the nra
on a more aggressive path at the same
time a decision by the supreme court
allowed for unfettered political
spending the nra refocused on campaign
donations and fundraising funneling
millions into local state and national
elections in the process they gained
some serious lobbying power not that
much gun control was liable to happen
under the winner of the nra's first
presidential endorsement ronald reagan
energized by reagan's win the nra pushed
legislation that protected the gun
industry that included the firearm
owners protection act which restricted
inspections of gun dealers loosened the
rules on interstate gun sales and made a
federal database of gun ownership
illegal speaking off the record some
politicians admitted that they only
voted for the law because they were
intimidated by the nra's power what a
system of government we have other big
wins included making it extremely
difficult to suit gun manufacturers
removing law enforcement's power to use
discretion when issuing concealed carry
licenses and preventing local
governments from regulating firearms but
as the 80s more on nra membership
started declining once again it would
take the threat of new federal gun
control to bring the organization back
to life jim brady was serving as white
house press secretary when he was shot
and partially paralyzed during an
assassination attempt on reagan in 1981.
his attacker coincidentally was just
released from prison and now has a
sizable social media following because
uh
we live in a weird world brady and his
wife became gun control activists and in
1988 they introduced the brady bill
requiring background checks on all
handguns sold by licensed dealers it
finally passed in 1993 followed by an
assault weapons ban in 1994 both of
which inflamed the nra as the washington
post explains in its book guns in
america nra rhetoric got gnarlier and
gnarlier in a fundraising letter
president wayne lapierre wrote that the
assault weapons ban gives jack-booted
government thugs more power to take away
our constitutional rights break in our
doors seize our guns destroy our
property and even injure and kill us
when one time nra member timothy mcveigh
blew up the alfred p murrah federal
building in oklahoma city in april of
1995 the nra was criticized for its
anti-government rhetoric which some
thought encouraged the militant why ever
would they think that the organization
tried to improve its image under the
presidency of famous actor charlton
heston through great pr moves like
holding its national convention in
denver
two weeks after columbine surely a
mistake they'd never make again except
for when they did the exact same thing
in houston three days after the uvalde
shooting great job nra really good
really good planning more strategically
the group allied heavily with george w
bush's campaign in 2000 leading to this
delicious bit of pr for everyone within
the sound of my voice
to hear
and to heed
and especially
for you
mr gore
from my cold dead hands
citing bush's eventual victory fortune
magazine ranked the nra the most
powerful lobbying organization in the
country but the oughts brought victory
after victory the assault rifle ban
expired in 2004 and in 2008 the supreme
court knocked down the dc handgun ban
ironically the nra may have lobbied its
way out of relevancy the organization is
strongest when people feel their gun
rights are under attack the organization
would eventually lose steam in the late
2010s thanks to lawsuits leadership
scandals bankruptcy filing that was
rejected and overall declining
membership their political donations
have proportionately dwindled down
although they still managed to spend
over 29 million dollars in the 2020
federal elections with the nra dying a
slow death it's worth asking
what does that mean for gun culture
honestly
not a whole lot
gun rights continues to be a winning
issue for republicans courting primary
voters lawmakers might no longer fear
retaliation from the nra but they do
fear looking like they're trying to take
away people's guns meanwhile gun sales
have nearly tripled since 2000 spiking
especially over the past three years
presumably so people could shoot the
novel coronavirus and not get sick we
live in violent times with american gun
deaths up 34 from 2019 and that's a 49
increase over the previous five years in
the last 10 years the figures risen 75
with faith in law enforcement generally
down it's no wonder the people are
looking to arm themselves or increase
their stockpile and that idea brings us
back to the issue of self-defense which
has been sold as the central reason to
buy a gun since the mid-19th century and
has only become a more compelling reason
in recent years
honey can you bring mommy the mob now
wanting a gun to protect yourself in a
country that's swimming in them is fair
but if you think owning a gun makes you
pardon the expression bulletproof the
data really doesn't bear that out
estimates of the number of defensive gun
uses range from 100 000 to over 2
million per year depending on
methodologies sample size and the
definition of defensive gun use given
discrepancies and data criminologist
thomas gabor recommends looking at
police officers as a reference point
since they are armed trained to wield
guns and not infrequently encounter
danger according to james fife an expert
on police gun use a big city cop is
involved in a shootout every 450 years
on average again that's every
450
years on average
almost half of a thousand years another
calculation found that in any given year
only one in 170 cops is involved in a
shooting as gabor concludes these
numbers show that even police officers
who are armed and are more routinely
involved in dangerous situations than
the average citizen rarely rely on guns
when doing police work unless they're
talking to a harmless young black person
then they definitely need guns no that's
not going to go in the video but it's
true this raises the question why would
people doing far less dangerous jobs
need to be armed all the time but
there's a much deeper problem with the
self-defense argument research from the
centers of disease control and
prevention found that more than
three-quarters of homicide victims knew
their attacker because of this bringing
a gun into the home actually poses more
of a threat to the residents than it
poses defense against intruders sort of
like if you bring 36 beers into your
house you're more likely to get drunk
from the beers than if you didn't bring
the beers into your house was that a
scientific comparison no but if you
bring 36 beers into your house what do
you think's gonna happen this is
particularly true for women who are two
to four times more likely to be
intentionally killed by a gun if they
live in a house with one if the person
you're most afraid of is the person
sharing your bed putting a gun under
your pillow
isn't exactly a setup for safety as
harvard professor and public health
expert david hemingway summarizes
scientific studies suggests that the
health risk of a gun in the home is
greater than the benefit and that a gun
in the home may more likely be used to
threaten intimates than to protect
against intruders add to that the
increased likelihood of homicide suicide
and accidental deaths occurring in
houses and guns and it becomes an even
more dangerous prospect by the way we've
linked to domestic abuse and suicide
support lines in the description this
all suggests that on a micro level the
mere presence of guns increases the
likelihood of multiple forms of violence
this has been borne out in other
countries for example when israel
stopped letting soldiers bring their
guns home on weekends soldier suicides
decreased by a staggering 40 percent
this all suggested having guns around
simply makes violence more likely again
if you're in a bar you're more likely to
get drunk if you're in a bathroom you're
more likely to go to the go to the
bathroom the failure of guns to deter
crime are clear on a regional level as
well in 2014 the south was the region
with the highest rate of violent and
property crimes the northeast had the
lowest 42 percent of households in the
south had a gun compared to 25 of houses
in the northeast as gabor concludes
these regional comparisons provide no
support for the idea that higher gun
ownership levels serve as a net
deterrent to crime now there's an
obvious reason gun sales tend to go up
after a mass shooting people want to be
prepared although they account for
approximately one half of one percent of
gun violence in the country mass
shootings garner the most headlines and
political attention and this makes sense
though we're more likely to be killed by
a family member or a friend than by a
stranger mass shootings remind us that
we can't simply avoid gun violence just
by being nice to our mom or picking the
right friends the first modern mass
shooting as defined by journalist seamus
mcgraw who i would bet my life as a
catholic occurred in 1966 when a man
opened fire from a tower in texas and
killed 17 people and so the romanticized
image of the lone american gunman
protecting himself from bears mutated
into the lone gunman turning his weapon
on innocent civilians with no clear
motive or agenda over the coming decades
the mass shooter typically young white
and male would become a collective
boogeyman in the american psyche tonight
authorities say they've arrested the
alleged gunman identified as an 18 year
old white male from conklin new york in
response to recent mass shootings
including the one at uvalde elementary
there have been calls to arm teachers we
should be skeptical of the idea that a
good guy with a gun could offer much
protection in the event of a mass
shooting first of all not even cops who
are trained hit their target the
majority of the time indeed inspector
kevin maloney of the nypd reported that
in 2017 city cops hit their target just
44 of the time also if there was a
platonic name for an nypd cop it would
be kevin maloney logically you would
have to expect a teacher to underperform
a cop and in a crowded public space
missing your mark can mean killing
someone else secondly having multiple
people firing guns at a crime scene is a
recipe for police confusion and chaos
police learned this at the texas tower
in 1966 when several onlookers started
firing back at the shooter stoking even
more panic journalist seamus mcgraw
writes in his book from a taller tower
that is john mcdonald executive director
of security at jefferson county public
schools told the denver post in such
situations adding another gun to the mix
can have tragic consequences thirdly
modern firearms have become so lethal
that a bystander can't really prevent
profound loss of life in one example in
ohio the police responded within seconds
but not quickly enough to stop the
shooter from killing 9 people and
wounding 27 more even if jason bourne
was your teacher even he likely couldn't
respond in time given these facts the
result of fbi studies of 270 active
shooter scenarios make sense they found
that only 3.9 concluded with a good guy
with a gun firing a shot meanwhile 11
were stopped by unarmed civilians again
that means that unarmed civilians have
done more to stop mass shootings than
good guys with guns what's more if we
want to know what happens when you have
more good guys with guns in their
pockets we can simply look to some latin
american countries where guns are
basically ubiquitous yet certainly have
not made communities safer rather
well-armed countries like guatemala
honduras and el salvador have some of
the world's highest homicide rates as
rebecca peters former director of the
international action network on small
arms argues a society that is relying on
guys with guns to stop violence is a
sign of a society where institutions
have broken down it's shocking to hear
anyone in the united states considering
a solution that would make it seem more
like colombia also worth noting many of
those countries have guns because reagan
shipped them down there in the 80s you
just google that it's all real i swear
to god in contrast though switzerland
has a high rate of gun ownership but a
very low rate of gun homicides in part
because guns are mostly seen as official
military weapons rather than tools for
self-defense switzerland brings us to a
separate question why is america so
uniquely violent compared to other
wealthy nations there's a lot of factors
but you probably won't be surprised that
other countries are worried that
american violence might be contagious as
then prime minister john howard said
after australia's port arthur massacre
in 1996 we do not want the american
disease imported into australia unlike
in america mass shootings and comparable
countries have been followed by sweeping
gun control action and while it's almost
impossible to imagine america taking
action to meaningfully curb gun violence
at least with all the partisan gridlock
in play many other countries have pulled
it off after the previously mentioned
massacre australia swiftly rolled out
stringent gun ownership requirements and
restrictions along with a huge gun
buyback program after a school shooting
in the uk also in 1996 parliament rolled
out a similarly strict set of laws and
there hasn't been a school shooting in
the uk since in other words the onion
got us again which makes it all the more
depressing that american gun violence
continues unabated
73 percent of mass shootings in
industrialized countries have occurred
in ye olde united states even though we
make up just 5
of the population as of early june there
had been more than
250 mass shootings in the u.s
this year alone
where does this uniquely american
violence come from according to mcgraw
some of it is the result of a media
culture that valorizes fame he writes
that thirst for fame runs deep in our
culture and it can make people do
terrible things now obviously america is
very much a fame obsessed society but
there are plenty of aspiring celebrities
all over the world and you don't hear
about scottish goths shooting up schools
for the cloud so that still doesn't
explain what makes mass shootings so
damn american some of it's rooted in
good old-fashioned prejudice frequently
mass shooters are taking their anger out
on an identity group whether another
race as in buffalo religion as in the
tree of life synagogue or women as in
isla vista california but in recent
years there's been a chilling
development of mass shooters streaming
their violence and going viral in the
dark crevices of the internet this
strengthens the idea that they're
searching for
some sort of twisted glory maybe in
their heads they are the lone american
gunman romanticized throughout our
culture indeed mcgraw notes that certain
types of guns take on a fetishistic
element amongst mass shooters a sort of
twisted extension of our national love
of guns when a mass shooting happens
there's an instant rush to figure out
the cause of such senseless violence and
there's inevitably talk about the mental
illness crisis in america which while
being a very real problem is a bit of a
misdirection stats suggest that up to 61
of mass shooters have some form of
mental illness and certainly if america
had better resources for mental health
care maybe those shooters could have
been treated before resorting to
violence
but what about the other 40
while certainly not in a great headspace
given the whole mass shooting thing
these people aren't explicitly mentally
ill rather they often exhibit signs of
narcissism with a deep sense of
grievance against the world we can't
just go arresting all the narcissists on
the off chance that they can go postal
can we wait can we because i i have a
list of some narcissists in my life that
i would love to give the authorities
what's more some 80 of guns used in mass
shooting were purchased legally
so it's not like better enforcement of
existing laws could have stopped them
there is one thing most mass shooters
have in common though domestic violence
over two-thirds of mass shooters either
killed family or intimate partners or
were involved in domestic violence
disputes on a larger scale the overlap
of domestic violence and mass shootings
suggests that rather than being some
kind of fluke or outlier they are an
extension of the broader structures of
everyday american violence much of which
is predicated on the extreme lethality
of modern guns so is there something
embedded in the dna of america's history
that just makes us more prone to shoot
people we're not sure but it does seem
like a series of factors ranging from
america's colonial past to western
expansion to an economy built on war to
an emphasis on individual liberty above
all else to underfunded mental health
care to the way domestic violence is
ignored until it becomes lethal yeah
that's a lot of stuff there's a lot of
things
oh that's it's very overwhelming these
things have all coalesced in the modern
era to make america number one in mass
shootings and other gun related deaths
and because it's not just one or two or
three things at the root of this problem
it sadly seems like there's no easy fix
but hey you can use an online dating app
um meet and marry a swiss national and
then you can live in a country where you
can own a gun and eat unlimited
toblerones without worrying about mass
shootings but what do you guys think is
there something inherently violent about
america can our gun violence problem
ever be fixed if you know please let us
know in the comments and don't forget
that we've linked to resources for
domestic abuse and suicide prevention in
the description we've also included a
reading list in the description if
you're interested in learning more now
smash that subscription button like a
satanist destroying butter jesus and
don't forget to ring that bell a huge
thanks to our patrons for all your
support be sure to check out our
revamped patreon page and remember to
check out our new stream wisecrack live
that takes place every thursday right on
this channel and as always thanks for
watching
later
[Music]
that makes no sense to me i guess or
boomerangs like murder weapons
there was blade boomerangs
[Music]